c'est une bonne nouvelle vous diront les
économistes l'augmentation de l'indicé
des prix à la consommation qui a atteint
un sommet en juin avec une hausse de 8,1
pour cent a reculé en juillet se situant
à 7,6 pour cent une différence qui
s'explique surtout avec un
ralentissement de la croissance des prix
de l'essence est le facteur qui tue le
plus facilement observable par monsieur
et madame tout-le-monde parce
qu'évidemment on le constate chaque fois
qu'on croise une station d'essence
le prix à la pompe reste tout de même
élevé pour certains consommateurs cette
prochaine
c'est vraiment très cher surtout si
quelqu'un qui travaille comme
raison de gilbert ahnee la moitié je
paye la moitié pour l'essence a marché
pour moi ça reste pour moi la
consommation de l'essence où il en
laissant ce qu'on fait attention jusqu à
l'envers on fait plus d'attention la
baisse du prix de l'essence fait du bien
aux portefeuilles tandis que le coût du
panier d'épicerie une autre composante
du calcul de l'ipc reste élevé certains
aliments ou enregistrer une croissance
accélérée tels que les les fruits frais
ainsi que le café et le thé conséquences
pour certains il faut jongler avec ce
que l'on peut s'offrir je vais pense -
parce qu'il me cacher des choses moins
10 maisons prada lui les
quelque chose de bon aux pillages en
ville et des biscuits ou quelque chose
d acheter les choses il faut réfléchir
un peu plus pour ça mais c'est aussi
pour aller faire une activité il faut
appeler avant pour savoir combien ça va
coûter pour les mois à venir les
économistes prévoient un ralentissement
de l'inflation ce qui apportera un peu
plus de prévisibilité pour les chaînes
alimentaires et on pourrait même revoir
certains rabais sur les rayons sauf pour
deux grandes catégories d'aliments des
prix alimentaires risquent d'augmenter
surtout pour deux catégories
principales belle la boulangerie et les
produits laitiers la commission
canadienne du lait a déjà indiqué une
hausse de 2 cents le litre à venir pour
le 1er septembre il si carla oliveira
radio canada montréal